pegasus un logiciel d'espionnage
israéliens déjà accusé l'année dernière
d'avoir servi à pirater l'application de
messagerie whatsapp aurait permis de
surveiller des opposants et des
personnalités religieuses au togo cette
fois c'est ce qu'affirme une enquête
comme une des quotidiens le monde et de
guardian qui s'appuie sur les données de
citizen lab le labo de recherche
canadiens qui se penche sur l'espionnage
informatique
parmi les personnes ciblées de religieux
le père à fognon et monseigneur alors
nous président de la conférence des
évêques du togo et 2 politique
l'opposant raymond rougeau ainsi que
l'ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères du pays elliott ohin tous ont
en commun leurs critiques envers la
présidence du pays qui est aux mains de
la famille gnassingbé depuis 1967
l'actuel président faure gnassingbé a
repris les rênes du pouvoir après le
décès de son père gnassingbé eyadéma en
2005 et s'est fait réélire en février
2020 pour un quatrième mandat
accusé par ses opposants d'user
d'intimidation et de pratiquer
massivement la fraude électorale
il reste néanmoins à la tête du pays les
quatre opposants ont reçu un message de
la part de whatsapp les alertant qu'ils
avaient été victimes du logiciel pegasus
et il faut dire que pegasus est loin
d'être à son coup d'essai l'an dernier
whatsapp décèle une faille de sécurité
dans son système et grâce à l'aide de
citizen lab identifie 1400 apparaît
d'utilisateurs infectées à travers le
monde une centaine de membres de la
société civile
on est ainsi étaient espionnés grâce à
pegasus aux quatre coins de la planète
le logiciel a été élaboré par nso groupe
technology une entreprise israélienne de
sécurité informatique fondé en 2010 est
accusé depuis plusieurs années d'avoir
fourni des outils pour espionner des
défenseurs des droits de l'homme des
opposants des journalistes ou encore des
avocats à chaque fois nso se défend elle
affirme vendre sa technologie à des
gouvernements dans le seul but de lutter
contre le crime et le terrorisme selon
elle ses clients s'engagent par contrat
à ne pas utiliser ces outils pour porter
atteinte aux droits de l'homme en gros
ce que vous faites avec le produit que
nous vous vendons ne nous regarde pas
facile pegasus agit comme un virus
particulièrement sophistiqué et sincère
dans les applications de messagerie
sécurisée les plus courantes pour y
copier des données non cryptés avant que
l'application de les chiffres lors de
leur envoi par l'utilisateur
il recourt au cryptage pour échapper à
la détection des outils de sécurité
traditionnels
et dispose d'un mécanisme de
surveillance et d'autodestruction le
dispositif d'auto destruction intégrés
permettent aussi à l'attaquant d'effacer
ses traces une fois qu'il a récupéré les
informations dont ils avaient besoin
hop ni vu ni connu l'enquète du monde et
du guardian basé sur les conclusions de
citizen lab évoque au moins 130 cas
d'abus concernant des défenseurs des
droits de l'homme et des journalistes
dans des dizaines de pays
au mexique par exemple 25 personnes
auraient été ciblés en 2018 le lanceur
d'alerté doivent nous donne en
collaboration avec citizen lab affirmé
que pegasus avaient été utilisés par les
services saoudiens pour suivre à la
trace le journaliste jamal khashoggi
sauvagement assassinée ensuite tandis
qu'au maroc pegasus est mis en cause par
amnesty international dans l' affaire
d'espionnage
outre le journaliste marocain omar radi
malgré les dénégations de nso qui assure
ne faire que fournir un outil de lutte
contre le terrorisme
la procédure lancée contre elle par
whatsapp en octobre dernier suit son
cours le 17 juillet la justice
américaine a ainsi estimé que la
procédure pouvait se poursuivre peu de
chance néanmoins d'y voir un
rebondissement d'ampleur ce genre de
pratique étant tellement courant que les
issues sont souvent les mêmes affaires
place et vendre des technologies
sophistiquées est une chose tout à fait
banal dans une société capitaliste et
lorsqu'il ya une offre et une demande
l'éthique peut parfois n'arriver qu'en
second plan xv en a produit à y point
barre la manière dont y utilisera ce
produit ne concerne plus x le marché est
conclu
tout le monde est content enfin presque